sarah's kidnapped
rape and murder
was one of the most dreadful events in
the 190 year history
of the metropolitan police service
this hearing has revealed the full
brutality
of this man's crimes against sarah
i am absolutely horrified
that this man used his position of trust
to deceive and coerce sarah
and i know you all are too
his actions
were a gross betrayal
of everything
policing stands for
what he did was unthinkable
and appalling
he showed himself to be the coward he is
through his lies
and seeking to minimize his true
responsibility for his crimes
police officers are here to protect
people
to be trustworthy courageous and
compassionate
his every action
is the exact
opposite of that
as the judge said
he has eroded the confidence that the
public are entitled to have in the
police
it is critical that every subject in
this country
can trust police officers when they
encounter them
and the judge went on to say
he has very considerably added
to the sense of insecurity
that many have living in our cities
perhaps particularly women
i have followed this investigation very
closely
i have been in court yesterday and today
i am absolutely sickened
overwhelmingly
my thoughts are with sarah
with her family and her friends
her loved ones
he will now spend the rest of his life
in prison
i hope that will give them
some
slight
comfort
this man has brought shame on the met
speaking frankly as an organization we
have been rocked
i do want to thank everyone involved in
bringing him to justice
and doing so so swiftly
sarah's courageous and dignified family
and friends
the prosecution team
and all those who supported
the investigation and prosecution
the judge recognized and commended
the work of our investigators
i echo those thoughts
i saw for myself firsthand
their extraordinary determination
and professionalism
this is the metropolitan police service
i know
it's capable and caring
it's full of people
who are good
and who work all their lives to protect
others
i absolutely know that there are those
who feel their trust in us is shaken
i recognize that for some people a
precious bond of trust has been damaged
our dedication to you
our public remains undiminished
as commissioner i will do everything in
my power
to ensure we learn any lessons
i know
that what happened to sarah
and indeed what has happened to other
women
in london and beyond in recent times
has raised important questions about
women's safety
here in the met i commit
to keep working with others to improve
women's safety
and reduce the fear of violence
there are no words that can fully
express
the
fury
and overwhelming sadness
that we all feel about what happened to
sarah
i am so
sorry
[Applause]
i